but for example on our team while we did
do the initial prototyping and have all
like the action game stuff worked out
eventually we had people joined who did
work in on action games like for example
our lead designer uh a guy called
yamato-san he worked on uh the original
Devil May Cry even like he's like in
classic like the OG of like action game
stuff and and that was where like you
had that initial sort of maybe pushback
of like I don't think this can work
because all the action games I work with
like you couldn't restrict movement like
this and but I was like No just we we
got to go with this because that's
what's going to make us like different
than the other games
um push to push so yeah so you you know
it could have been easy just to like
fall back and be like yeah you know
you're right it's you know let's just
make it like a normal action game but
um I think if you have that really
strong Vision you kind of have to like
hold your ground and like really see it
to the end and if if in the end it
doesn't work out then you can you come
back and do it but